>> Tucker: YOU CAN DEBATE THE
SPECIFICS, BUT IN GENERAL, MOST
AMERICANS SEEM PRETTY HAPPY
CONGRESS WAS ABLE TO PASS IN A
PACKAGE THAT BENEFITS ORDINARY
PEOPLE AS WELL AS COMPANIES.
THE BILL IS SO GENEROUS IT GIVES
AIDES TO MILLIONS OF
NON-AMERICAN CITIZENS, AS LONG
AS THEY ARE HERE LEGALLY.
BUT FROM ONE MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
THAT’S NOT ENOUGH.
IN FACT, THE BILL ISN’T
GENEROUS, IT’S AN INSULT.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE
DUMBEST, MOST UNHAPPY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, MAY BE THE ONE PERSON
OUT OF 435 WHO HAD NO INFLUENCE
ON ANYTHING AND YET STILL DOES,
HAS DENOUNCED THE STIMULUS
BILL BECAUSE IT LEAVES ONE GROUP
OUT: ILLEGAL ALIENS.
IS SHE REALLY WORKING FOR THE
RNC SECRETLY?
PROBABLY.
IN HER VIEW, PEOPLE WITH NO
LEGAL RIGHT TO BE HERE, PEOPLE
FILLING AMERICAN JOBS, CROWDING
AMERICAN HOSPITALS, LOWERING
AMERICAN WAGES, GOOD PEOPLE BUT
NOT AMERICANS, VIOLATING OUR
LAWS, FOR AOC, THESE PEOPLE
DESERVE AID, JUST LIKE AMERICAN
CITIZENS, THE ONES WHO ARE
HURTING AND OUT OF WORK.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT THAT IDEA?
WE’VE BEEN SEEING POLLING ON IT,
BUT YOU WOULD THINK THE NUMBER W
IT WAS FOOLISH TO THINK THAT
DURING OUR STRONGEST PERIOD, OUR
RICHEST TIME, AMERICA COULD
PROVIDE FREE EVERYTHING TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD, BUT TO DEMAND
THE SAME THING WHEN THE ECONOMY
IS ON THE EDGE OF COLLAPSE?
AND TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS ARE IN DANGER?
THAT’S NOT DUMB, THAT’S A